hi I'm Abby Brown and we're here at the
Wolfram technology conference these are
a few of my students hi my name is Emily
Zhang hi I'm Shannon Brownlee we're from
Torrey Pines High School in San Diego
California and we're going to be talking
about our new club that's about
computational thinking CT @tp
a be brown and these are my students
Shannon and Emily who will be presenting
here with us as we talk about our high
school computational thinking Club so a
little bit about me my name is Abby
Brown as I said and I teach at Torrey
Pines High School in San Diego
California I've been in Mathematica user
since 1992 when I was in college and
I've been teaching since 1996 and for
much of my career I've been using
Mathematica with my high school students
I recently started a computational
thinking Club at the high school and
this is what we wanted to share with you
today Emily and Shannon are students who
are in my calculus classes last year
they participated in a summer training
program using the Wolfram language with
augment software and now they are
leaders within the club for other
students we have two other related
presentations at the conference
following this talk Ryan
Theo and liket Paulo Mandela will be
talking about their wolfram summer camp
experiences they are my students and
Isaac Gelman who's a graduate who worked
with me the last couple of years will be
speaking with Eric Nelson about the
augment software training this afternoon
at 4:30 in this room throughout the
presentation there are images with the
slides that come from different
activities that we've developed for the
club and I could give a 20-minute talk
on each one of those images and where it
comes from and how we put that together
so I'll try to hold back a little bit
but I remember I'll mention something
about each one so this one the idea was
an activity to create a word cloud based
on a favorite song so students would
find lyrics and then find a related
image and then put it all together so
the word cloud would wrap around that
image so why am i doing a club like
where is this all coming from
so my driving question in this was I I
wanted to find a way to reach students
who were not in my current classes and
introduced them to the Wolfram language
there you know there's so many more
students at the high school who could be
interested in this how can I start
showing them what we can do and what
really inspired me to do this was after
a few years when I was unable to come to
the Wolfram technology conference I
returned in 2016 and learned a lot more
about the kind of new features of the
Wolfram language the you know stuff with
image processing and and geo data and
and all this stuff that was like way
beyond just you know graphing curves and
equations and you know solving algebra
problems which is kind of our primary
focus with Mathematica I also was a
little selfishly motivated I primarily
teach juniors and seniors and I thought
wouldn't it be amazing if the students
came into my classes having some Wolfram
language experience rather than waiting
until they're a senior and saying hi
here's some great program and then you
know they leave and that's great that
they take that knowledge with them but I
think how much more could we do if there
was more experience coming into my
classes one of the obstacles to that
goal however has been working with other
teachers at my site I'm kind of the lone
wolf in using the Wolfram language a lot
of the other teachers always say hey
that's cool that's interesting you know
or maybe they help them make a graph or
something but they just don't have time
to really delve into it and of course
there's also now so many free online
resources that seem easier to use to
just get results that they need
immediately in their classroom just go
ahead a page down so - so 2016 is when I
had kind of the first inspiration like
let's do this and what we started what
we called the Wolfram language of
workshops and a couple students were
excited by this about this idea we
created these posters that were all
mysterious and just hung them up all
over campus and to see who would show up
and they'd learn like what this is all
about and we had several students that
interested we tried tried to keep things
kind of informal I didn't want this to
become like this huge obligation on top
of everything else we have going on so I
figured let's meet just a couple times a
month like sometimes we met on a Tuesday
sometimes we met on a Thursday and we I
didn't wanted to try using the
elementary introduction to the Wolfram
language ewi l as just sort of a guide
like hey let's just work through these
problems and exercises and do this well
there were some challenges to this that
ultimately led to the failure of the
Wolfram language workshops and one of
the most immediate issues was the lack
of a regular schedule the students are
very busy and having something that
doesn't met sporadically it was hard to
get students to like oh I can't come
this time or you know that day doesn't
work for me and so it just fizzled out
pretty quickly with maintaining student
interest and ability to come the I also
didn't want it to beat another class for
me to prep that was something I was
really trying to avoid like now I'm
writing new lessons and doing all that
so I'm already doing that for three
other courses the the student leaders
that were so excited with me
taught on a real early case of
senioritis as well and senioritis is
real I live it and and it didn't help
either because it all sort of fell onto
my shoulders and it just kind of fell
apart the other thing that came up was
the ewl book didn't work very well as
our sole resource what I found was it
was you know a lot of these little neat
examples but the students kind of lost
motivation and interest because they
didn't really get to see in that alone
where it all could lead like how do I
put this together to do something really
great it's like well this is this nice
little thing this is this nice little
thing but like what am I doing with this
so I came back to the conference last
year and found a new inspiration really
a big theme throughout the conference
last year was this idea of computational
thinking and computational essays and I
realize that that's more my theme it's
rather than focusing on
like oh we're gonna learn this
programming language like let's do
computational thinking and I thought
this might be a new way tied her tap
into things with the club I also
connected with the computational
thinking initiatives and learned about
some of the resources that they have
available to share in the type of
environment that I'm working with I also
committed to a new structure I said
we've got to do this weekly or it's not
going to happen based on the experience
of the previous year and so what we did
was we pretty much always met on the
same day but occasionally I'd sprinkle
in a different day because there would
be maybe people who couldn't always do
Mondays and I made each I didn't make
every week like a lesson so some things
were like activity days some days were
Explorer days so it wasn't so much that
I had to like prep for it and you know
create all these lessons I also had new
student leaders who were really excited
and committed and we spent more time
with those leaders forming a vision for
the club before we actually launched it
and the those student leaders would
eight were able to create some of their
own activities they led activities and
they supported new students who came in
throughout so we might have some brand
new student and they could sit with them
on the side and help them get started
while we could continue on with our
activities activities were created by me
we could use some of the AI adventures
from the computational thinking
initiatives and like I said some of my
students created some activities of
their own we also had some times during
our Explorer days what I like to call
computational thinking conversations a
student would ask a question and we just
start coding and trying to see if we
could solve this question kind of like a
live coding experience on our computer
screen and I've saved some of those and
put them on our website we've talked
about topics such as machine learning
image processing interactive animations
with manipulate text analysis and some
3d printing which reminds me that the
prints are getting passed around so if
you haven't seen them yet you can
configure into new to pass those around
so we had success from last year the
student attendance increased and they
really seemed to enjoy the different
activities some were using Mathematica
and the Wolfram language and to do stuff
for their math classes
and a few students really did a lot and
got really involved and spent a lot of
time with the e WI L book and got into
their own projects in particular three
students Ryan and Lucas who were
presenting after me and a third student
Spencer decided to do a machine learning
project and at the time these were
students who were not in my current
classes so they were taking the class
that leads into mine and they're only
mathematic experience had been through
the club and they did a project that
they'll talk a little bit about later
and then Ryan and lik ahthe attended the
wolf from summer camp from that
experience and now all three of the boys
are part of the leadership team within
our club also my selfish goal got
somewhat realized as well because I do
now have students who are in my calculus
classes who got a little more Wolfram
language experience before we started
things off and I have students taking my
project space class which is all about
Louisville from language and and
Mathematica who probably wouldn't have
otherwise been there because they had
been inspired through the work with the
club so I'm gonna turn it over to Emily
who will talk about some of her
experiences all right hi everyone
my name is Emily zhang and i'm excited
to share some of my experiences using
Mathematica alright
so my first exposure in using
Mathematica was through miss Brown's
calculus class and it was very helpful
to be able to visualize a lot of the
different math concepts and my other
than being part of the computational
thinking math club another great
experience that I had was through doing
the final project end-of-the-year final
project for my calculus class and I
wanted to incorporate something related
to triple integrals so I used a book
problem as you can see on the board so
that problem it was a very interesting
problem asking me to find how much work
it would take to form a mountain or
specifically Mount Fuji and so all those
well I use triple integrals and I solved
the problem but I wanted to
um be able to like have the listeners
people to visualize this problem and so
I was curious about how could I use
computational thinking to model a
mountain and so with miss Browns
guidance I was able to create that one
line of code so we were able to model a
mountain using data from an image and so
as you can see in the top left corner
you can see this a little white like
circle over there and that's the Mount
st. Helens and then if you can scroll
down so I propped the image and I was
able to find the contour plot and if you
can scroll down you can see I created a
3d model of the mountain based on data
from an image and so Miss Brown said
there was like probably another way to
do this and so I was curious and I
searched through Wolfram documents
documentation center and I came up with
another method and this method was I
could create this 3d model using just
data directly from Mount Everest and if
you can see that is a model 3d model of
Mount Everest cool alright and if you
can scroll down and so I was curious I
wanted to bring in some more concepts
that I learned in calculus class which
is contours and so I creatively was able
to create this contour plot using this
infinite viewpoint thing it was very
interesting ok and so now with these
cool functions in hand I was able to go
back to my original problem which I was
able to create this 3d model of Mount
Fuji and a contour of Mount Fuji and if
you can see it is it's actually not
really a contour it's a 3d thing but we
were able to creatively do it using
infinite viewpoint function alright so
um one thing I really like about using
computational thinking is where one
exploration leads to another and we
didn't just stop here
I was curious on how I could model these
mountain using 3d using a 3d printer and
then we have 3d prints floating around
here yeah and so one thing that's really
great about this is that we're able to
use these 3d models and their contours
in mrs. Brown's class when she teaches
calculus and I'm also planning on
creating a lesson plan teaching students
about modeling mountains and other geo
functions in computational thinking Club
so and so now um Shannon will present
some of her experiences using
Mathematica okay hi hello I'm Shannon
I'm a senior in miss Browns advanced
topics projects class right now and I
took her calculus classes last year I
was first exposed to coding my freshman
year when I tried to join girls who code
at my school and after a few meetings I
just really got bored of it we did Java
it just didn't quite make sense to me it
didn't really click and so I kind of
gave up on coding for a while and then
my junior year in Miss Browns calculus
class she started using Mathematica and
with that we would do manipulates to
model things we were learning so like
infinite series or quadric surfaces
things like that and it really helped to
learn all kinds of abstract ideas just
by seeing like oh here's what happens
when you change different variables
here's what happens if you rotate it it
was a super helpful tool for a lot of us
in the class especially since we're very
visual learners and so going into that
when we started to do more projects into
it and she started her computational
thinking Club I thought it would be a
great place to learn a little bit more
about coding and maybe try and get into
it again and so I went to a few meetings
and I thought it was such an interesting
idea and a very cool language to learn
especially in comparison with my three
days doing Java
because it they had all these built-in
functions they had all this stuff that
was very not self-explanatory but very
easily comprehensible where you could
tell like based on the name of the
function what it did or if you'd had any
questions it was super simple to look it
up in the function like thing and in the
elementary introduction book and so
through that I really got into coding
and when it came to the end of the year
for our final class projects I thought
doing something with Mathematica would
be a super cool way to really explore it
and get more into it and thus my
adventure in Mathematica began my
partner and I decided to be a little
more creative and make it harder on
ourselves so instead of finding a
problem in our textbook we decided to
make ourselves a problem and we used
Mathematica to code this lovely little
Candyland we have up here and we used
all kinds of surfaces we found and all
kinds of mesh functions and color
functions to make it look really nice
and then we used our calculus knowledge
from in class to define gradients
contours and all kinds of stuff for this
little plot and through that I learned a
lot more about Mathematica and the inner
workings how syntax works that kind of
stuff
and going into that project taking on
building this Candyland with very very
little Mathematica experience was very
difficult but also very fun to see how
you could go into it knowing nothing and
learn so much just by like testing it
out going through the elementary
introduction the documentation center
and all that and through that I got even
more into it and I thought I really want
to continue on with this Mathematica
seems super fun and interesting and so
when this broad approached us with the
option to do a summer program with
augment software I thought that would be
a very fun way to continue on and to
learn more and so we got connected with
Eric we did a lot more in the elementary
introduction book and learned the we
started from the bottom the very basics
of Mathematica and the inner workings
all kinds of stuff like that and he
taught us more about computational
thinking and how to use the
documentation center and all kinds of
stuff just to figure out how to sell
a problem even if you know nothing about
the functions that you would need to
solve it and so through that when we
went into advanced topics which is our
project space Mathematica class at our
school through that all of my work with
augment carried with me and so when we
went to the beginning of the year and
we're learning the very basics of
Mathematica over again for people who
don't have any experience with it it was
very helpful to be like oh even though I
only started this a few months ago I
still am able to help others who are
brand new with this and just seeing the
the amount of growth and knowledge that
I had gained over a few months to doing
just a few projects was a very
interesting comparison with a lot of
other like languages and projects and
things that I've taken on because it was
so easy to understand and to get better
at and thus I began helping other
students in the class with their
projects when they were having some
trouble you know helping them debug find
a bracket here and there and then when
she approached us with the opportunity
to help out with a computational
thinking Club at school I thought that
would be a great opportunity to help
other students and so we're there in the
class helping other students and after
school in the club we're helping people
who have zero Mathematica experience we
sit with them we help make sure that
they can keep up with everything in the
presentation answer any questions they
have and it's just incredible to go
completely full circle in probably about
eight months from sitting in the
computational thinking Club knowing
nothing doing one of her activities to
being there helping her run the
activities helping new students with
their first introductions to Mathematica
and then creating our own notebooks and
interactive projects to do so we'll turn
it back over to Miss Brown to discuss
our future so I've got lots of ideas and
of course coming to a conference like
this always just means more ideas but
one of the things we want to do is
continue to advertise and recruit
students throughout the year it doesn't
have to be like if you miss the boat in
the first two weeks you you can't join
us we want to continue to develop new
activities we want I
want to get more student-led work so
it's less of me doing the instruction
more the students the continue doing
these computational conversations those
were some of our most fun and
interesting moments last year the
there's additional Wolfram resources I
want to explore computational thinking
initiatives resources the Wolfram
challenges Wolfram you the notebook
archive which could also be a great
place for students to publish and share
their own work with the world and
continue working with the elementary
introduction book I want to continue
developing the Future student leaders so
when these fine students graduate I'm
not starting from scratch next year
that's one of the challenges certainly
in an educational setting is you know
making sure you have that continuity so
if you are interested in seeing a little
bit more about what we're doing or
you're curious about all these notebooks
and things these images that are coming
up they are from notebooks on our
website it's Abby math comm /ct for
computational thinking the computational
thinking initiatives website has
additional resources if you're thinking
of something you might want to start up
in your own environment continue using
the text and even the some of the
articles that Stephen Wolfram has
published recently about computational
thinking on his blog have been really
kind of motivating and guiding in terms
of this idea of what is computational
thinking and what are these essays and
having the students read them and see
some of the examples that he's presented
there has really helped us kind of get
things rolling as well so I think we
have a couple minutes for some
additional questions but I do want to
thank everybody for coming in and
sharing your time with our presentation
today and we'll be around this afternoon
and tomorrow as well
so thank you very much
you